в одеському порту на число і не судно
радує про чорноморський флот України та
афіша донни давно розміщувався в криму тем
годині самому помсти за баракатом і смішки
в ато буріла а близько сотні людей в
які називають себе віддай ську дружиною в
астане кирик одним і вечеря видавець
стрима ось і радикально, але що в них
людей при сотні на приковують на світі
повторить і частку кримом провести
референдум побачите до складу Росії
мрії русія за сотні вже за 70
кілометр vida dice та
плутайте big кордону розтушоване
придністров'я місяць на обличчі повністю
закладіть друз і айві відкриту Петро йому
з апарат este в одесі
український лауреат намокає сапери skoda
кільцем його за злодії, що проводили by лісу.
контроль
навчання україну Петро йому та євросоюз
andreas наш до з федеральної поліції не
машини в ікону і на кордоні
межах європейської прикордонної місії
допомога українці там зручна
з 1988 вирву я чому проти ти йди
ральної про кордоні службі то день і
ніч інакше було поділу на те що purple
я перебуваю суміші та в регіони секцій маму
валют році ці годинники за ціль big україна
орієнтована на sachen за тайгою
про придністров'я авторитарно держава
тесла пов'язана з москвою до столиці
викликану придністровською республікою
дорога в так я повз підрозділи російських
весь просто йшов інших тут з 1990 року іншу
руку у тирасполі ностальгія за райськими
години ми просто живиця приховати 3 і далі у
придністровській силі дзержинське на
кордоні з молдовою розуму через
зустрічається тут світлану з нього
нову баладу продукті вайікра думайте я
києву цьому придністров'я призначають ешиве
завдяки фінансові то по морю з Росії
ost astrum придністровці тест поживають
май же задарма світла і а тобі шість
місць всього населення не мріє про
відсилання в цю Петро йому я визнання ду
росії
євро європа тут нікому не по три дні все
хоче в Росії офіційно проходячи про
включення odu складу росії ж класти
у Москві доступний кордон вид за
жіночого придністров'я до безглуздих
молдові шекель касат моя 3-го чоловік
Валентина Миколаєва та друк брунова
конфлікту у 90 хвою вів проти рідні
строгий а ось так сьогодні жінка виступаючи
за союз росію способи стоять за росію
чому я хочу знову жити і я коли
тут у молдові проводить на політичні
мотиви ж економічніше придністров'я в
бути значного шукаємо та пенсіями які
фінансові москва 1 для цілого Валентина
я тобі зараз місця в їх пансіону риму
села зростання майбутній придністровський
паспорт давінчі тією ціною до
так я моїм shahram агенство від ув
70-их я проти laune їх платила там
свої подарунки паспорт cool ice у врожаю
республіки травня тут і багатого молодих
людей
знаємо краще знати і роботу в Росії
закині європе не належного перед
камерою у них теж місцях не
налагоджується корито когось росію ути
молдова можна заплатити за це високу
політичну ціну
отже Москва ж знаючи нібито спориш одне
роздають че паспорт і можна розширити
свої кордони